this is a production of cornell
university
okay thank you michael very much for
your very nice
introduction and thank you all for
showing up
to my seminar so i will have
a few background slides before getting
into my labs
ongoing research which is focused on
resistance to aluminum think
heavy metal strategies in weed
mates and model plant species
plant needs essential nutrients for
their lives
and survivor the essential nutrients
can be classified into two groups
the non-mineral and mineral nutrients
the basic non-mineral nutrients
are supplied to plants by the air and
water
so such as carbon dioxide and
ho h2o
where the mineral nutrients of
supplies to plants through the soil
there are six macro and
seven micronutrients
the micronutrients have
a narrow dynamic range between
sufficient requirement and toxicity
there are also metals and metallized
with
no structural and cellular functions
such as aluminum cadmium
and arsenic they can be toxic to plants
under certain environmental condition
besides cadmium and arsenic
can be harmful to human beings once they
get
into human food chains
the soil provide plants with mineral
nutrients
however plants encounter various soil
space
antibiotic stresses including
drought and flooding
mineral deficiency high salinity
and heavy metal stresses adverse
soil ph either too low or too high
these antibiotic stresses can severely
impair plant growth and development
causing yield losses so my labs
ongoing research is focused on
low ph and heavy metal
stress
the non-accumulating plants took
two general strategies to cope with
aluminum and heavy metal stresses
the first is the so-called exclusion
mechanisms
with these mechanisms plant roots
release
organic compounds to the rhizosphere
the organic compound can form
non-toxic complexes with the toxic
metal ions and
prevent them from entering the root
cells
the organic compounds include organic
acid
that's the most common one phenolic
compounds and successor noise etc
the second strategy is the
internal tolerance mechanisms
which deals with toxic metal ions inside
the plants there are two
avoidance approaches so through
moving the toxic ions
away from the most sensitive part of the
plants
the second approaches is to sequester
the toxic metal ions in the vacuole
of the root cells or the shoot cells
and also different toxic metal ions
have different targets for plants for
instance
aluminum toxicity may be targets at the
root
especially the root tips of the
non-accumulating plants
in contrast heavy metals
such like a zinc targets at the leaves
so the alumni research in wheat in my
laboratory
aluminum toxicity occurs when soil ph
is below 5.5
so at the neutral ph aluminum is bound
to the soil
however when ph is dropped to below 5.5
5.0 the toxic
aluminum ions al3 plus
is released from the soil which could be
highly toxic
to plants so this photo shows two
wheat lines one is the torrent line the
other is
sensitive one so we can see under
neutral ph
the growth of these two lines
was relatively fine i mean normal they
are all normal
however under the low ph you can see
greatly inhibited root growth of the
sensitive line
but the total line growth was
just fine
so the limited root growth
will affect uh plants water
and nutrition uptake and cause
severely yield loss for the sensitive
plants grow on the essex soil
many years weed aluminum resistance
indicated that wheat aluminum resistance
relies on root excitation of malate
uh to the rhizosphere so maybe from the
root tip
of the atom line this process
is facilitated by an aluminum
activated melee transporter
t8 amt1 the amt1 is constitutively
expressed in the root tape of the
sensitive line
but not in the in the total line sorry
but not in the sensitive line also
tamt-1 is the first aluminum resistant
gene
cloned implant however
whether an internal detoxification
mechanism
is involved in wheat aluminum resistance
remain unclear
so in my lab we use model
to facilitate wheat aluminum research
so the first mother species is arab
arabidopsis
aluminum resistance in arabidopsis
is facilitated by aluminum activated
excitation of male from the root type
and citrate from the more mature root
region
so root melee and situate release
are mediated by at amt1
and atma atmt1 that's aluminum
made a transporter atmate is a
signal transporter so these two
transporters
are functional hormone of ta amt1
so the first aluminum gene column in
wheat and as we made the second
aluminum resistant gene term in sorghum
respectively so this result
indicate that aluminum resistant
mechanisms
are conserved between monocots
and die cuts so thus
knowledge obtained from arabidopsis
studies could help with research
in return
uh the second model species we
used is hygienia
hygienia is an aluminum hyper
accumulating plant
it can take up and accumulates large
amount of
aluminum in the shoes without showing
toxicity symptoms
and hydrogen have two colors
of flowers so either red or blue
amazingly the color differences
is not due to genetic variation between
the two
plants they are genetically identical
because of soil ph plants have red
flowers
on the neutral ph soil
and blue ones on acidic soils
how can ph change the color of high
angio flowers the reason is aluminum
so under neutral ph so there's no
aluminum taken up
by the plant and no alumina in the sea
puff so the flower we see is the sepal
it's not
a petal and so the
petal and the flower show the native
color
of red of the enthalpy stored in the
vacuoler of the sepal cells
under low ph or acidic soil condition
the root take up aluminum release from
the soil
and transport them to the shoe and the
finally the flower and into the
vacuole of the seapo cell
where aluminum and enthalpy form a new
complex
this complex uh it's blue in color
so that's the reason how and that's how
the
color change happened
uh dr kumi yushida's lab
from japan um naigoya university
they cloned two transporters
responsible for the input
of aluminum across the plasma membrane
and the tonoplast or vacuolar membrane
of the cpu cells so we can see
under no
uh low ph so aluminum was taken up and
transport
to the cytosol and the um
vacuum over so this the secret of the
magic
so um okay go back a little bit so the
plasma membrane the localized
uh trans aluminum transporter is named
port
stands for plasma membrane aluminum
transporter
and also the thermoplastic one called
what vacuolar membrane aluminum
transporter
both port one and water one are
members of the aquaporing gene family
in hygiene so for for us we
study aluminum resistant and the
research is for the horticulture chain
and then we ask could aquapori members
be involved in aluminum resistance
in plants so we go back to uh
advertising uh phylogenetic analysis
indicate that the part one of
um hygienia plans
it's closely related to
uh the nip sub family of the aquaporin
super gene family nip stands for
naturally 26 like intrinsic
proteins they are dying members in this
sub-family
and to test their function we acquire
individual tdna insertion lines for each
members
of the subchin family and found out that
the nip 1-2 mutant lines
are more sensitive to aluminum toxicity
compared with the wild type so these are
three independent mutant alveolar
they are they have the comparable growth
uh with the wild type but are more
sensitive to aluminum toxicity compared
to the wild type
so this suggests that the wild type
nip 1-2 genes are
involved in aluminum resistance in
arabidopsis
so nip 1-2 is localized to the plasma
membrane
so when it expressed in the east
cell the fusion nib 1-2
gfp protein is overlaid with
the plasma membrane staining as you see
here
and this arrow points to
the vacuoler of the yeast cell
also in the native plant root
we can see the fusion protein
it's overlaid with the plasma membrane
marker also and so that
that indicate that 1-2
it's a plasma membrane localized protein
then we use yeast system to test
aluminum uptake activity and
aluminum transport substrate of the
nip 1-2 protein what we found that is
nip 1-2
transport aluminum melee complex
but not aluminum ions or aluminum ions
conjugated with different cellular
ligands
and we further test the
uptake transport activity for
nip 1-2 in east
through influx and efflux actually
the result shows the net influx
aluminum uptake activity mediated by
the nip 1-2 and also
we can see efflux activity
also mediated by knit 1-2
so these results indicate that nip 1-2
is
a bi-directional aluminum
metallic transporter
and so this is the my favorite part of
the research
so we found a jointed function of
amt 1 and mid 1-2
for aluminum resistance so this cartoon
shows a longitudinal section
of the rule uh of the rule
so this is the junction between the
roots
and the rhizosphere and this region uh
stands
out for the cell wall or apoplast
and this the plasma membrane of the
endothermal
cortical epidermis cortical
endodermal and pericycle or
the parenchymal cells of the
silent xylem parenchyma sorry
under low ph
the al3 plus ion
is released from the soil
which you can get into the apoplast
through epiplastic flow
and once in the cell wall the aluminum
ion
can activate the plasma membrane
localized
amt1 or the malay transporter
leading to the release of malay from the
cytosol to the cell wall
and further diffuse to the lysosphere so
in the rise of sphere
and as well as in the cell wall
um the release of malate uh
formed a complex with the
aluminum ion so that's aluminum metallic
complex as we i showed in my previous
slide
and this is the transport
substrate for nip 1-2 but
aluminum ion it's not the substrate for
uh nip 1-2 okay
and also we found that the aluminum
metallic
cannot enter to the ceiling blue cell
wall
so this the uh exclusion mechanism
and previous people thought oh that's
that's enough i mean for aluminum
resistance for
the aluminum mallet in the new cell wall
it's fine that's not toxic but in our
research we found that it is not the
case
they still have toxicity and this
complex
need to be further
removed from the cell wall by the nip
1-2
transporter so
the aluminum melee complex in the
cytosols
further transport to the xylem
parenchyma
and upload it to the xylen and
translocate it to the above
ground tissues so this is a internal
mechanism for resistance yeah we can see
the cooperation
between the exclusion mechanism and
the internal detoxification mechanisms
so what's the advantage of this
coordinating function
so where amt1 mediate
male excitation requires carbons
and energy yeah of course i mean mala is
a valuable
carbon source for plants however
nip 1-2 facilitate aluminum transport
it's an energy-free process so this is a
channel so it just moves
against the concentration gradient
so a coordinated function
of amt1 and knit 1-2
can create increased aluminum resistance
in a carbon use efficient weight so we
have estimated
root growth can increase up to 15
percent
with the inclusion of nip 1-2
besides amt1
so now go back to the uh we i mean so
our goal is for
for the crops so we want to use this
system to improve our weed
aluminum resistance as both wheat
and aluminum as
both wheat and arabidopsis
rely on amt1 mediate
root may metallic excitation for
aluminum resistance we hypothesized
wheat plants also have a similar
amt1 and nip 1-2
systems for aluminum resistance
so so come back to the two wheat line i
showed you before
so the sensitive uh igrad and the
torrents
kerosene hoe so we can see in the
sensitive line both amt
and nip 1 dash 2 expression
uh so we can barely see i mean
in the sensitive line however
in the thorium lines we can see aluminum
induced expression of the
the melee transporter gene and the
aluminum transporter gene
so that's the difference and uh and the
cost for
the resistance in in the torah line
and also we
measure the rule aluminum contents
uh in the blue cell wall and root cell
set
you can see the sensitive lines
has much higher aluminum content
in the root cell wall compared with the
wild type i mean the tornado line
and much less aluminum content in the
room cell set
compared with the torrent line so this
suggests that
a aluminum remover process
uh that remove aluminum from the root
cell wall
into the root cell step was
uh involved so this could be the
function of
nip 1-2
and then we further test the
um the read nip 1-2
gene function in arabic topics
so this arabidopsis wild-type plants
and the nip 1-2 mutant plants
so this basically is the wild type but
without the function of
nip 1-2 and then we transform
the ta
nip one gene the wheat gene into the
mutant line and evaluate their
performance under aluminum toxicity
so we got three independent
over expression line that express
the wheat gene in the mutant background
you can see not only the wheat gene
cause the skill of
rescue of the mutant phenotype
but the overexpression lines performance
even
better than the wild type
this indicates that the nip vantage 2
rentals superior aluminum resistance
so future direction for this week
started
uh to start the ta amt 1
and ta nip 1-2 interaction in wheat
plants
to examine tmt-1 and
ta 1-2 interaction and tested their
uh rows in aluminum resistance and
yields
in weed so we're not going not only to
test
the seedling but also want to see what
happens for the mature plant what's the
impact on the yields
finally we want to develop genetic
and all molecular markers that can
facilitate weed reading
programs so our research provides an
example
for using model organisms to
facilitate research in crops
so aluminum research inmates
it has been demonstrated that root
organic gas
excitation plays an important role in
aluminum resistance
in mates however real organic gas
release
could not explain the phenotypic
variation among mains varieties
so this means there is a different
different aluminum resistance mechanisms
in maze so we notice benzocessonoids
are a class of intel derived
plant metabolites so they are highly
abundant in mates
and other pca plants
which can account for more than one
percent of dry weight
of young seedlings and
it has been demonstrated that the bx
play important role was in resistance to
insert herbivores and pathogens
so our question could bs play a role
in aluminum resistance in mates
so here shows two main lines one
sensitive
the other tolerance so that's the root
growth
under aluminum stress and also we see
the
sensitive y has more aluminum
accumulation
in the root compared to the total one
suggesting an exclusion mechanism
and also we found that the torrent lines
release ben successor noise
upon aluminum stress but not see
the release in the sensitive line
and such release is aluminum
concentration
and aluminum treatment times dependent
and also we found there's no difference
in root are
aluminum activated organic acid
insulation between the two lines
so this indicates that aluminum
resistance
in this turbine line it's
could be caused by aluminum activated
uh benzocessenoid exultation
and lastly we applied
the pencil section noise to the
uh cultural
solution and ask if a subjuna
exogenously applied benzene sensor noise
can alleviate aluminum toxicity
yes indeed i mean we see this uh
aluminum along
and aluminum plus dimple and ample so
this two
uh bench obsessor noise so
both line the sensitive and the torah
line shows improved
aluminum resistance
and also we found out that
there's no difference in endogenous bx
levels
between the two lines under different
treatment conditions
so in summary it is the release of ex
but not their internal contents that
determine aluminum resistance
in mates however the
molecular and genetic nature of
how bx is transported
from the roots and how they are
regulated
so this is all unknown
yeah the the finest part of my research
is the zinc and heavy metal
resistance so for non-accumulating
plants
the above-ground leaf tissues are the
primary target
of zinc toxicity the symptoms
include chlorosis decreased chlorophyll
content
and photosynthetic activities
so for the non-accumulating plants a
internal tolerance mechanisms
could be explained for the resistance
so this mainly through
to avoidance approaches the first to
keep the toxic or exact
zinc in the roots
the second approach is to sequester
exact same in the vacuole of the root
cells
or the leaf cells or in the trichome
of the leaf or shoe tissues
so then we ask could acuplain
be involved in zinc detoxification
implants aquaporin is believed to
transport polar but non-charged small
molecules
however we identified nip 1-2
is involved in aluminum transport and
detoxification
and this also be identified in the
hydrangea plant
so based on this we hypothesized after
aquapori members could be involved in
heavy metal transport
and detoxification the rationale
underlying is that i think
sequestration in the vacuole of the roon
cell is critical
for zinc detoxification and the
type of members of the aquaporin
family are believed to be localized to
the vacuolar membrane
so tape stands for counterplot in
changeling
protein so the tunnel plus is equivalent
to vacuolar membrane
so we go ahead invest
whether tips are involved in zinc
detoxification yeah indeed we find
a mutant line for the
type 2-2 they're hypersensitive
to elevated sync content
so this the wild type and the mutant uh
grow under the control condition that
contain
two micromoral zinc but under
200 micromolar zinc condition
we can see the roots of the mutant
lights
are more strongly inhibited
compared to the wild type this suggests
that the tip 2-2 genes the multifunction
of the gene
are required for
sync resistance
so here is the summary for what we have
learned from
this study tip 2-2 is a plus
a tonoplast localized uh transporter
that facilitated zinc sequestration
to the vacuole of the root cells
and thus because the zinc
immobilization in the route
and limiting the transport
or translocation of excess sink from the
root
to the shoes in the above ground tissue
tip 2-2 mediates zinc transport
to the trigon so here is the image
of the zinc staining of the trichome
cell so you can see accumulation of the
zinc
in the trichome so this is also
one of the common the top detoxification
mechanisms
for both the non-accumulating
and accumulated plants
so uh heavy metal resistance
so i don't have time to go
into details for this project but i just
show
we have identified several critical and
our genes
that are involved in uh resistance
to academy and nickel
and zinc toxicity
so and
with this uh what's the application
and impact of my research on
plant breeding okay the knowledge of
wheat aluminum resistant genes and their
interactions
could be directly applied to wheat
breeding programs
we know that the tamt-1
gene or the malay transporter
gene has been widely used in
wheat uh breeding program but with the
inclusion
of the weed nip 1-2
that could be a bonus so uh to increase
the
resistance and yield in a
carbon use efficient efficient
manner also we would like to develop
genetic and molecular markers for
crucial aluminum resistant genes
and then use this for acceleration
of wheat breathing program
in addition identification of the nova
made
resistant genes so i this specifically
for the release of um benson cessna
noise from the roots
uh we don't know the transporter and we
don't know how
are the transporters being uh
regulated so with this knowledge
we can probably develop new tools for
mates uh breeding finally
knowledge obtained from zinc and heavy
metal research
can provide guidelines and new
approaches
to breeding crops with enhanced in
essential micronutrients such as zinc
and limited toxic metals
such as cadmium and arsenic
in the active parts of the crops
so with this i would like to thank
the former and current member of my
laboratory
and my collaboration
collaborator and some of them are listed
in this slide okay with this i would
like to thank you
for your attention and
like to answer questions
great thank you gbeng for a wonderful
seminar and great to see all this
molecular biology and to see how you
propose
its application to plant breeding is
very clear
and likely to be highly translational so
i thank you for that
and so if you if you would like you can
open up the the chat
now so that you can see the questions
being asked
by attendees yeah and i can also read
the
the questions as well so we have and
thank you for leaving time for the
q a part of the seminar and
for those of you who would like to ask
questions you can unmute yourself
and you can put
a question in the chat where you could
also
raise your hand and i will
call on you from mark sorrells
can the same transporter be functional
for more than one heavy metal
um so for
you mean the uh nip 1-2
i don't know if mark's referring to that
transporter or transporters
in in general would you like to clarify
mark in
in the chat or you can unmute yourself
as well
yeah i'm just thinking transporters in
general
it might facilitate learning mechanisms
uh if you found the same transporter
okay function for more than one heavy
metal
okay yeah so for the um
closer one let's
um yeah let me answer the question
for uh the aluminum transporter
so we found that uh the aluminum
transporter nib 1-2
it's specific very specifically
and it doesn't respond to other heavy
metals
but for the uh echo pouring
uh we do find cross
resistance such as zinc
and cadmiums
so because they most of time they share
the
same mechanism or transporter
for entering uh to the plant cell
does that answer your question mark
okay yes yes it does great thanks mark
there is a hand raise from kevin ahern
so kevin would you like to unmute
yourself
sure thanks michael um nice talk to you
peng i really enjoyed it
so the variation that you showed in the
two maze lines
benzoxazenoid uh exudation
were both um elite chinese germplasm
so yeah i think yeah i was wondering if
you've looked at we know that the
variation exists in the nam population
as far as benzax's xenon content goes
have you looked at variation in root
exudation
in the namm or 282 association panel or
anything like that yeah that's what we
are going to do that yeah so so actually
what we want to do um use the nan
population
not only to start the um the variation
first
we we definitely need to find out a
population population
with the variation and and also we want
to use the population for
mapping the genes and or the region
responsible for
the transport or regulation so that does
we can have
collaboration i think with uh at buckler
great thank you um i also have bx
mutants if you're interested
oh okay great great i mean that's great
uh yeah i mean we definitely can uh work
together yeah
so this all i think all the bx genes are
come through the association mapping to
my knowledge
or at least most of the time yeah that's
right
great thanks for your question kevin uh
now
turning to the chat a question from chad
are the trichomes and vacuoles equally
important in al sequestration
uh trichome and a l
c we don't notice uh so it's for zinc
so um so we haven't looked at
the trichome sequestration
for aluminum yet so the reason is that
the leaf tissue actually is less
sensitive to aluminum
so so one of the
aluminum resistance mechanisms is to
move
aluminum from the roof especially the
root tip region
up to the uh shoe so
yeah but to answer your question uh we
haven't checked for
uh the accumulation of
um aluminum or al
in the chaicon yeah but definitely we
have look into
the zinc zinc is the case it's one of
the
uh resistant mechanism
hey thanks for your question okay
from travis rooney the al tolerance
genes
what are the other effects of that gene
tradeoffs for yield in unmetal stress
environments
are these mechanisms required to be
constantly expressed for protection
or can they be turned on off by the
plant
oh yes i mean that's a great question
yeah this always there's trade-off for
resistance and survival and plan
definitely need to
find a balance between the two
yeah for the aluminum resistance gene so
so the one thing is they are all induced
by the aluminum stress that means
that the gene expression was low without
aluminum stress
so that's under gene regulation
level the other
level is on the protein uh so that's the
transporter activity
also is activated by
aluminum so this just make sure that
um plants encounter
aluminum stress and then plants
start to release uh the valuable
organic acids such as malay and citrate
so yeah but for the um yeah we have
recently have the papers
uh for the epistatic relationship
between
uh the malay transporter amt1
and the aluminum transporter
nip once they actually have aesthetic
relationship
very beautiful i think nature yeah so
only
when um after meta is released
then nip 1-2 star function
because the transport specific
specificity for the transport substrate
right so i hope i didn't confuse you
yeah yeah
travis any follow-up that was great
thank you thank you
all right those were two fantastic
questions from
two of our graduate students now moving
to rebecca nelson's question
piling on to kevin's and travis's
questions
are there trade-offs or synergies
between insects
disease resistance for al tolerance
since
bx is involved with both
all question oh yeah that's a very big
question yeah
so the answer i mean i don't know yeah i
don't know yeah
so uh uh the
the best success online um
their function has been widely started
in
uh insect resistant yeah so
so it's no no no actually there's no
reports for ben successionoid uh
in aluminum resistance so i think that's
uh so our recent paper is the first one
indicated that
the release uh of
exocytonoid from the roots
that is important for one of the
important
mechanisms for resistance
to in to aluminium inmates
but what's the relationship and how uh
increase this resistance and what's
their effects or impacts
on the resistance of on the
inside uh up over so we don't know yet
yeah so that's a good question that
could be a topic for research in the
future
great yeah i do find it fascinating that
that pathway is linked to al tolerance
because
after seeing like george jander and
kevin ahern's work on his pathway
mostly focused on like the pest you know
part
in in terms of the plant but then to to
see this it's yeah
it just re assures me mace is so
many secrets that we just don't know all
of them yet
yeah also i i read a paper i mean that
bx release
might also have some impact on the um
the micro microbial on the rise of
sphere
yeah so for oh i don't know yeah for
nutrition
release phosphate use
efficiency yeah it could be anything i
think
um simon joe working in george jander's
lab had
hints about its effect on the fusarium
complex that they
are contending with as they try to come
up in this cold wet springs that we have
so
it could be very interesting to look
into how
that functions for for like both the
ions and microbial uh challenges that
those ceilings are facing
cool yeah yeah i got actually i read
their uh
paper and so in the review paper they
mentioned
they surveyed the different mains line
with aluminum and different aluminum
resistance
but what they found is the uh probably
they just look at the internal
uh content of ben's accessories there's
no difference between the lines
so that's similar to our research and we
found no difference between the
sensitive
and the torrent line but the difference
lies in the
how much the succession is released from
the roots that's not the internal
content
very cool yeah okay our last question
here
doctor the you this is from xiaowei li a
postdoc in my group
okay compared with the it's uh it looks
to be a
a multi-part question okay
so just as a heads up compared with the
plant grown in neutral ph
soil the flower color of hydrangea
changes from red to blue apart from the
color variation from the perspective of
growth and development
are the red or are the plants with red
flower as healthy as that with blue
flower
that's the first part question
and and then i'll probably just read
like the last two questions because i
think they somehow relate to the first
one
in other words what is the cost of this
adaptation to low ph assuming crops with
such adaptation cause a decrease in
yield
okay so uh could you repeat the second
one i didn't
sure yeah so um you know in other words
what is the cost of this adaptation to
low ph
and that being the the change in color
oh okay so um i have to
um to emphasize i mean here
the hygienist plan
belongs to a hyper accumulator
so it's uh different from the most crop
plants like a weed and then there's all
uh non-accumulating plants so a few of
the
crops like buttery the
hyper accumulator but high ginger is a
hyper accumulating plants that means
they can
pick up a lot lots of aluminum from the
sawyer
and store in the lead or flowers
without showing any aluminum persistence
symptoms
so that's the uh so so with this i think
they're both very healthy uh for the red
and the blue uh flower the plant
and yeah that's another stress for them
yeah
perfect and i i guess then the last part
is probably more general
to the adaptation of crops to low ph
is there like a cost in terms of the
fitness
and will like the adaptation of crops
to low ph also in turn decrease yield
oh of course i mean as i mentioned i
mean there's always trade-off
uh between the resistance and survival i
mean
the plan need to invest some either
energy
or material and put them away from the
growth and develop
and houston for the resistance but need
to find out the balance i mean that's
an odd i mean right
yeah sure i mean that's the uh also the
breeding program yeah you you want to
create
a line they have the best
adaptation and also have the best
potential
for the yields so that's i mean uh
how to regulate the resistant
magnesium is very important so for
for another one i think the nip 1-2
um i think that's a wonderful choice
because
ant-1 is the major aluminum resistant
gene
and it require the release of malay
from the root although i mean it's it
could be control
but with the um addition
of nip 1-2 i mean this is not
energy cost without cost anything yeah i
was
all very minimal just express the gene
and it function so this yeah
great and i just wanted to to say that
every
one who had asked a question says thank
you
exclamation for your your answers
so okay they're all in the chat and then
the
the last comment is from chloe
and it's just sharing a a paper
on bx's and the soil
aspect of like the rhizosphere and in
growth
okay thank you so yeah if you'll feel
free to like pull that paper out
and thank you for that chloe
with with that um i think our time has
now come to
an end and we we thank you very much
dr liu yeah this has been a fantastic
presentation
and we we look forward to see where your
research takes you
in your lab in the future and it's
and it's going to be great to see the
applications of your research and how
it can impact plant breeding and crop
improvements so thank you very much for
sharing your
your time and thoughts today with our
section
yeah thank you for hosting yep my my
pleasure
see see you and everyone else next week
us
yes bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu